hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm going to
explain a 2017 american science fiction
movie called man from earth holocene
which is a sequel to a 2007 movie the
man from earth
the movie begins with the university
professor professor carolyn kitris
giving a tour to her students in a
prehistoric museum
she explains about homo sapiens living
in the holocene epic while not far away
a student separated from the group
isabelle is sketching skulls and
jawbones of the prehistoric human
she is accompanied by her best friend
tara who notices professor john young
lecturer on religion related courses
examining the prehistoric human exhibit
they gossip about him until they finally
decide to walk up and greet him
turns out he's there because he is
waiting for professor kitris his
girlfriend who is giving a tour tara
wants to take a picture with him but he
immediately changes the conversation
in the evening john is grading his
students work while carolyn comes and
affectionately greets him after that we
see liko a college student practicing
boxing before class
he is called by his friend philip who is
already waiting downstairs
after liko is ready they go to professor
young's class at chico community college
in the class they along with isabelle
and tara discuss similarities in
differences between buddha and jesus
after class they invite professor young
for a vegan dinner night celebrating the
end of the academic year but he politely
declines
professor young is approached by another
co-worker professor gill delivering the
news that he is now a grandfather to
celebrate the birth of his grandson he
asks professor young for a drink by the
sports stadium even though the whiskey
is awful they still enjoy the sunset
gill asks about whether john regrets not
having kids but john refuses to discuss
it
later that evening isabel comes over to
professor young's home while he is
cooking dinner delivering assignments to
be graded by professor kitris she asks
for the books that she can borrow from
professor young
he motions her to the den and says grab
all that you want
isabelle grabs a few books one of them
is written by arthur jenkins back in her
flat she is reading the book while
suddenly tara appears beside her after
coming back from a sorority party they
notice the book is signed by the author
with writings to my dear friend john
oldman but the spine has not cracked
meaning john has not read it based on
the date on the author's signature they
deduced the age of professor young and
become confused because why would he be
called old man when he was supposedly
about 30 years old at that time they
look up arthur jenkins on the internet
finding out that he is a renowned
archaeologist and has written a book
about conversation with the man from
earth a university professor practicing
buddhism claiming to be 14 000 years old
that book is considered science fiction
by the academic community even though he
claimed it to be non-fiction which
disgraced jenkins they deduce the man
from earth's descriptions match
professor young's
isabel and tara go to philip's house in
which lico is also there they
enthusiastically explain about their
findings about how jenkins book tells
the story of an immortal man who knows
many things and teaches at local
colleges has virtually no presence or
any records on the internet avoids
having his picture taken and changes
identity every 10 years
however his first names are always john
with last names taken from modified
versions of historical terms
liko and philip deeply questioned the
truth about the story especially philip
who was a firm christian believer but
agrees to help the girls find more about
professor john young
meanwhile far away in searchlight nevada
art jenkins is seen gardening with his
pig betsy he comes home plays online
chest then notices an incoming email
from isabel chang asking about the john
oldman he wrote in his book he suddenly
becomes emotional and replies that she
better go to hell
not receiving any good response from
jenkins the students break into john and
carolyn's home to find more proof
in the basement liko finds a box of
books each written by different johns
and takes pictures of them isabelle
notices carolyn's car in the driveway
and warns her friends to quickly escape
before that she manages to take a photo
of john and carolyn's photograph in the
living room although john's face is only
shown sideways
fortunately the house has a back door
and they successfully escape
they did more about the identities of
the different johns
each identity seems non-existent with
each publisher not having any contact
information about the author anymore
meanwhile john feels he needs to go
hunting in the woods
even though carolyn is reluctant at
first finally she lets him go
he argues that he does not feel like
himself lately and needs to bond with
nature he drives his truck to the woods
and spends the night there in the woods
john is making fire using stone like a
prehistoric human his hand bleeds in
surprisingly does not seem to heal as
quickly as it should although confused
he heads back home
isabelle calls jenkins again this time
directly saying that she believes her
professor john young is john oldman
jenkins does not answer it but he
listens to the voicemail carefully he
replies to the message by saying that he
wants to talk only if isabelle can send
him a clear picture of john young
after that isabelle receives a call from
an old woman saying he knows a man named
john plice back in 1957 in a small
college in idaho the description of the
man matches john young that call is a
response from the many emails and calls
isabelle and her friends have sent in
many colleges across the states which
might be where professor john young
worked at some point in time isabel liko
and tara try to take a picture with
professor young by offering him coffee
before class but john conspicuously
messes up the shots to not fully show
his face after class they try to
convince philip again to believe them
but philip is still skeptical especially
by the fact that john young could be the
jesus christ figure all christians
worship but they do not give up so late
at night liko and isabel sneak into
john's window and take pictures of him
sleeping isabel sends the pictures to
jenkins to which he agrees to meet and
talk to john
he bids goodbye to his pig and prepares
to go on a road trip
meanwhile tara comes to john's office at
the campus and flirts with him but he
rejects her and gets her out of the
office
unfortunately during flirting she claims
that she knows about john's true
identity
john feels he is in danger so he talks
to gil that he wants to quit and can
recommend a replacement lecturer for
next term gill is disappointed but
eventually accepts him
at home jon tells carolyn that he needs
to go and although carolyn is
disappointed as well she accepts him
because there is nothing she could do
tara confesses her actions to isabel
which surprises her saying that tara's
words might make jon disappear sooner
they call jenkins who is still two hours
away from them so they have to keep john
young from leaving until jenkins gets
there
john is burning his only photo with
carolyn then gets ready to load his
belongings into his truck until the four
students show up and confront him
isabel shows him jenkins book and wants
him to admit that he is john oldman the
living embodiment of jesus christ
john refuses and after a brief
conversation the students leave
however liko tases him from behind and
he falls unconscious due to his head
hitting the pavement meanwhile art
jenkins car breaks down on the middle of
the road so isabel tara and liko decide
to pick him up while philip is in charge
of the unconscious john and is supposed
to call an ambulance for him however he
ties john in the basement when john
wakes up he asks sean about the truth
john begs that philip cuts him loose but
philip is confused and anxious
he agrees that he would release john if
john tells him the truth
john confesses that over two thousand
years ago he taught a group of people
basic spiritual wisdom then it developed
into christianity and people called him
christ
philip seems to believe that but when he
takes a knife and is about to cut john
loose he doubts him again as he thinks
john is supposed to have magical powers
to free himself he begins to question
john again and gets furious as some of
john's replies contradict sayings from
the bible that he truly believes in
he is not satisfied with john's
explanations and deduces that he is not
christ but antichrist instead
john counters him again saying the
antichrist concept never exists in the
bible and never refers to a single
person
philip still clouded by his emotions
accuses john again of being the seven
headed beast from the book of revelation
who can heal miraculously and plans to
gain massive followers on earth
john denies it then asks philip to
either stab him or let him go
after a while philip decides to stab him
in the heart believing that if john is
truly jesus christ he would not die
however jon seems to die after the stab
blood trickling down from the wound
philip is shocked and leaves abruptly
on the road isabelle and others try
contacting philip to no avail so they
begin to worry about him and john
they arrive at john's house only to find
blood trails from the basement in the
basement they find a broken chair and a
pool of blood but no sign of anybody
they decide to call every nearby
hospital hoping that philip and john are
already in hospital and john is
receiving medical attention while still
being very confused at the scene in the
basement
then john is seen waking up at a cave he
is called upon by a man approaching him
harry who brings him clothes and other
survival gears
turns out harry knows john's secrets he
asks john to come with him as his dad is
sick to which john agrees then they get
in harry's car and leave
in the mid-credits scene an fbi agent
comes to jenkins front door and asks him
questions
the descriptions of john young match
those of witnesses of several unsolved
murder cases in the past
he asks jenkins if young is capable of
violent actions
jenkins replies that he does not know
although he believes anything is
possible
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching